[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight here's a funny thing
that we noticed the other day
people debate all the time about mass
immigration
what you never hear anybody do is make
the economic
case for mass immigration and here's why
our country's economy is becoming more
automated and tech centered by the day
it's obvious that we need more
scientists and skilled engineers but
that's not what we're getting instead
we're getting waves of people with high
school educations
or less nice people no one doubts that
but as an economic matter
this is insane it's indefensible so
nobody even tries to defend it
instead our leaders demand that you shut
up and accept
this we have a moral obligation to admit
the world's poor they tell us
even if it makes our own country poorer
and dirtier and more divided
immigration is a form of atonement
previous leaders of our country
committed sins we must
pay for those sins by welcoming an
endless chain of migrant caravans
that's the argument they make if it
sounds like something that some dopey
sociology professor at long beach state
thought up half drunk in the 70s
you're right that's pretty much exactly
what it is and yet somehow the
immigration as
atonement idea has become the official
position
of virtually every guilty liberal in the
united states are tech overlords
the ones always lecturing you corporate
america nancy pelosi and
paul ryan they all believe this and
anyone who disagrees with them is
denounced as a bigot
and fired what's so amusing though is
that nobody ever bothered to explain
any of these rules to the people of
tijuana
tijuana is in mexico which means they're
mexican citizens
and by academic definitions popular in
this country they must be oppressed
nobody in the american left ever
imagined that the people of tijuana
would display the classic symptoms of
white privilege
and yet when a caravan of honduran
immigrants showed up in their city
uninvited
that's exactly what they did you know of
incidences
here in tijuana and in other cities that
some of these people that are coming
into these
with these caravans are committing
crimes this is not about racism
we don't dislike a certain group of
people because they're from a country
one country or another we are here
because our government
has not taken control of these
what we call invasion your country have
to be beware
of these people because they are people
they are bad people
well it sounds like a trump rally when
did mexican citizens start talking like
this it's confusing and of course it's
also deeply hilarious
and pretty satisfying to watch what's
more predictable
is how leaders of the caravan are
starting to talk suddenly they sound
like community college professors from
long beach
entitled cut off from reality and highly
aggressive
yesterday a group of leaders of the
caravan marched into the u.s consulate
in mexico and demanded 50 thousand
dollars
in exchange for returning to their own
countries huddled masses yearning to
breathe free
nope cynical shakedown artists who've
been watching too much cnn
no surprise there when rich liberals
tell you that america owes you
a comfortable life nobody should be
shocked when you believe them
well gennaro lopez is a municipal
official from tijuana an elected
official
he's not a bigot he's not suffering from
white privilege or toxic masculinity
he's just a citizen who's upset about
what is happening to the city he loves
he joins us from just across the border
in tijuana
mr lopez thank you for joining us we in
the united states were told
that the migrant caravan would make our
country better would improve america
has the migrant caravan made tijuana
better what has been the effect of
having the caravan in your city
hi tucker good afternoon from tijuana
and
things are getting better they're
probably getting worse
last weekend we issued an ultimatum to
all the hondurans and guatemalans
that are uh camping out here on the
street they're blocking
the street and they're playing all their
necessities trashing the street and
we have a school close here this is the
third week being closed and they won't
open this
until these guys leave and we shoot an
ultimatum
for three days friday saturday and
sunday they have to go
sunday they will be removed by force and
a priest came here he's very well known
father
and he talked with them and said they
shouldn't go the did you stay that he
would talk to the federal authorities
so sunday the director of disaster
relief
from mexico city he issuer in order to
stop
and don't remove them by force so
they're still here
uh problems are still going on
uh there's been like 280 arrests it
before it was only for drug possession
and being drunk in the streets
now it's for breaking and entering into
homes people have even made
citizens the rest of them and things
aren't very nice around the neighborhood
is tired of them the merchants and the
schools
so you've had home break-ins are are you
certain that it was
migrant caravan members who broke into
those homes
yeah there's a video on facebook and in
the video video he says his name
and he says he's from honduras how are
the police hands
we had well
well these are on 24 hour alert on this
end
and they're worried about this because
we don't want crime rate to go up here
in mexico
we are very tourist town and we live of
tourism and
christmas season is one of our best
times for
for tourism here and for sales and
things aren't very good
right now also uh we don't want these uh
migrants to make the u.s nervous and
they
had two marches this sunday from the
other the new shelter
they made a march to the u.s consulate
and they
delivered two letters one was directed
directly to
president donald trump and they were
demanding that he didn't give him
if he they didn't get political asylum
from the u.s
he should pay them 50 000 to go
honorably back home and also they were
demanding that he
should extradite uh president juan
orlando hernandez from honduras
to the united states and he should
remove 13
big military bases
and big businesses from the united
states that are in honduras and they're
accusing them of depleting
the on their own economy so they're
demanding money or they won't leave that
sounds like an extortion attempt
yeah like sounds like a ransom yeah
do you want them to go back you have to
give 50 000 to each one of them
uh like 700 have been yeah
i would just say that political
political leaders in the united states
encouraged this caravan and media
figures people on television in this
country
encourage the caravan to come north now
they're in your city what would you say
to the politicians
and media figures in the us who
encouraged them to come to tijuana
well tijuana is a great town uh it
it opens its arms to anyone who wants to
come here in peace
and to live here no problem but if you
come here
in a violent move if you
where uh come here against our
sovereignty
uh you're not welcome here really we we
don't want this problem we have our own
problems
and we're dealing with them yeah we
don't want problems from other countries
to start invading us here
and create creating this all this habit
that has been happening
you know closed schools people living in
the street home invasions i can see why
our heart goes out to you mr lopez thank
you very much for that update tonight
okay thank you
immigration used to be considered a
matter of policy and people debated it
on those terms now increasingly the
question
is framed in theological terms one of
america's great moral leaders nancy
pelosi
does that here's an example
most of us speaking for myself
considered the wall
uh immoral ineffective but he also
promised mexico would pay for it
so even if they did it's immoral still